pas
[Musique]
ce lundi 19 août jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse est arrivé à la réunion pour
toujours de physique
il est rappelé aux colosses de la pointe
des châteaux à saint leu pour déjeuner à
la cantine avec les élèves accompagnés
du coup
moniteurs et directeurs vela juden
marine la restauration scolaire une
compétence départementale qui revêt des
enjeux importants en terme de santé
publique et économique la collectivité
s'est engagée dans une démarche de
promotion et de valorisation des
produits locaux dans les restaurants
scolaires même toujours aller à la
cantine avec les avec les enfants
d'abord ce ça me permet d'observer que
les cantines en france et
particulièrement la réunion ne cesse de
progresser avec de plus en plus de
circuits courts et les choses qui sont
meilleurs que lorsque moi j'étais élève
et puis surtout un plaisir d'avoir
discussions avec les avec les élèves
parler de leur quotidien faut toujours
se mettre un petit peu dans la peau des
élèves pour essayer de faire progresser
le votre école
l'éducation de nos enfants est une
priorité pour le département et bien sûr
quand le ministre se déplace il est
important que on aille à sa rencontre
aussi comme les collèges dépendent du
département eh bien il est important de
faire passer le message que sur un
territoire comme la réunion nous avons
une jeunesse qui ne demande qu'à
exprimer ses talents
une jeunesse conquérante qui doit être
soutenu et c'est le propre de
l'éducation nationale plus d'offrir les
meilleures conditions de travail à nos
enfants nous l'avons fait pour les
collégiens ont pu partager un repas avec
le ministre
c'est bien parce que je suis content
qu'une personne aussi importante que le
ministre vienne dans notre collège
derrière et je ne vais expliquer ça à
mes copains qui sont pas dans un collège
leur dire ça chatel ne cadrent bien que
si moins de repas sont servis aux fumées
de 35me demi pensionnaires parmi les
cinquante cinq mille collégiens 2
[Musique]